لا يوجد شيء غير مطروح على الطاولة بين قائمة طويلة
من العقوبات ، هناك أداة واحدة
لا يبدو الغرب حريصًا على استخدامها
، سأفعل كل ما في وسعي
للحد من الألم الذي يشعر به الأمريكيون
في مضخة الغاز ،
وهذا أمر بالغ الأهمية بالنسبة لي ، نعم نحن  لم
تمس تدفقات الطاقة على الإطلاق أه ليس
قليلاً وهكذا إذا كنت لا تزال تشتري
الغاز الروسي أو نشتري الغاز الروسي ،
كما تعلم منذ ستة أسابيع ، فأنت لا تزال
تشتري الغاز الروسي اليوم
وخوفنا السائد خلال العشرين عامًا الماضية
كان أنه سيغلق صنابير
الغاز الطبيعي أو النفط إذا
واجهته وأعتقد أن هذا لا يزال يمثل
خطرًا وتهديدًا حقيقيًا للغاية أه تعرف
اليوم وإذا قرر الرئيس الروسي بوتين
تسليح النفط والغاز
التزام التحالف الغربي
ستوضع العقوبات على
المحك ويقدر جيه بي مورغان أن سعر النفط الخام
يمكن أن يرتفع إلى 150 برميلًا إذا
تم تخفيض صادرات روسيا بمقدار النصف ، الأمر الذي من شأنه أن يؤدي إلى
ارتفاع الأسعار في مضخة الغاز
وتفاقم ما هو بالفعل الأعلى.
التضخم في 40 عامًا ،
فربما يفعل ذلك إذا تم حبس جميع هذه الإيرادات
في حسابات بنكية أجنبية
بسبب عقوباتنا ربما تكون
صحيحة ويمكنك بسهولة تخيل سيناريو
يقول فيه إذا لم أستطع الحصول على المال على
أي حال إذا كان كل شيء  أن تكون محبوسًا
في نيويورك أو محبوسًا في لندن ، ما هي
النقطة التي قد أقوم بإيقاف تشغيل
الصنابير بها ، وبالتالي هناك القليل من
لعبة القط والفأر التي تم
تطويرها الآن لمحاولة تحديد
من سيفعل ماذا ومتى و  ما هو
الانتقام الذي سيكون متاحًا